in the midst of economic crisis Greece
took over the six month rotating Council
of the European Union presidency antonis
samaras was to face a number of tough
challenges one of those was rules for
supervision of banks the so-called
banking Union which has now been
officially adopt a mystic our monetary
union is now much better equipped to
avoid future crises and better prepared
to face them if they do happen some
Greek emily's did not share the same
enthusiasm the troika in Greece governs
the country without having any
legitimate to do it mr. Barroso is
satisfied with the great presidency
because the presidency didn't do nothing
to create new initiatives the difficult
decisions were however adopted under the
Greek presidency notably on the issue of
immigration now the presidency rains
have been handed over to Italy for the
next six months following the election
of the European Parliament president it
was the turn of the 14 vice presidents
to be elected by their peers the vice
president's replace the president under
certain circumstances beyond their
protocol and administrative role the
vice president's also have an influence
on Parliament's political direction como
uno su trabajo excessive priests exact
concept fellatio on trollee por la haute
cuisine Tony Ellis institutions hope el
cielo busca la vía model for the success
or Isis grooving see ya defrosted some
treasures to assess hilarious kaleido
MEP is also Alexei Daniel Chrestus that
is the people he managed the parliaments
budgets and internal operations they
also lay down rules for the institution
both inside and around the hemi cycle
negotiations were in full swing at stake
the composition of the parliamentary
committees political groups advance
their priorities within these committees
apoptosis antonio del grupo technically
a development pratik episode reward will
exist in curry co op le socialist lapel
peer-led bae ho dong y de TI vedo Kozak
to dubois na certain Commission
d'onofrio osceola a petition de Serres
dollar commission presidents and
vice-presidents of the parliamentary
committees are still to be chosen long
negotiations may be up ahead